the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi the aim of our lecture today is to
present with what is perhaps the single
most powerful recipe for evaluating
indefinite or for that matter definite
integrals
it's called integration by parts and
therefore the today's lecture is called
integration by parts and what I want to
emphasize is essentially that this is a
technique which shows us how to find
indefinite integrals but that in theory
it changes nothing over what we've had
before this is essentially as we've
mentioned a recipe for being able to
simplify or reduce indefinite integrals
to things that we can handle well it
Kappa it centers around the rule for
differentiating a product and to show
you what I mean by that let's just barge
right into this thing in differential
notation recall the view and V are
differentiable functions of f of X the
differential of u v is u times the
differential of V plus V times the
differential of U and solving for u DV
just transposing we have that u DV is
the differential of u times V minus VD u
now what we do is is we integrate both
sides of this equality on the left hand
side we have integral UDV
on the right hand side recall that the
integral of the derivative just gives us
back the original function in other
words if we integrate the parental of u
v up to an arbitrary constant we get
back u times V the integral of VDU we'll
just denote by integral VDU and observe
that there's really an arbitrary
constant coming from this term an
arbitrary constant coming from this term
an arbitrary constant coming from this
term but it's the sum and difference of
arbitrary constants is still an
arbitrary constant we can neglect all
the constants here and just lump them
together and at the end write plus C or
we can leave the C off making it implied
that the arbitrary constant is contained
in the symbol integral VDU all right now
we've done this but a much more
important question would be our
exclamations for that matter would be so
what
see who cares where this happens to be
true or not the answer is weak here
that's why we're making up a lecture on
it and the reason that we care is this
that frequently for a given u and v u DV
may have a completely different nature
about it then does v d you in so far as
being able to find the integral now
again the best way to show what we mean
by this is to choose a particular
example let me start just arbitrarily
here picking a couple of simple
functions for us to differentiate but or
to integrate let's pick u to equal X and
V to equal sine X now it's simple to see
from this example that in this case if u
equals x and V is sine X then DV is
cosine X DX
in fact let's write that down so we can
see it here notice that in this
particular case integral u DV is
integral X cosine X DX u DV on the other
hand what is V D u V is sine X then
since u equals x since u equals x D u is
DX therefore V D U is just integral sine
X DX now look at these two integrals
this one we can integrate just by
looking at it it's minus cosine X this
one well offhand we don't know a
function whose derivative with respect
to X is X cosine X however by this
recipe we now have a way of showing how
to compute U DV u DV once we know
integral VDU in other words in this
particular problem letting u equal X and
DV being cosine X DX we can proceed as
follows namely by this recipe we get
what integral X cosine X DX is equal to
this as u DV equals u times V recall
that U is X via sine
so U times V is X sine X minus integral
V do you okay but V is sine X D U is DX
so we wind up with this but now we know
that the integral of sine X with respect
to X is minus the cosine X the minus and
the minus cancel to give me a plus and I
wind up with that the integral of X
cosine X DX is X sine X plus cosine X
plus an arbitrary constant okay that's
all integration by parts really is that
all we do here is we evaluate one
integral by knowing another integral and
by the way what I meant him when I said
that one did not have to change any of
the theory what does the integral mean
here anyway what we mean by this is what
find all functions whose derivative with
respect to X is X cosine X now what
integration by parts did for us was it
showed us how to get this result but if
we didn't know how to get this result
observed that we check the answer the
same way as always namely one thing that
hopefully we can do is differentiate
this thing and if we differentiate it
let's see this is a product it's the
first fact that times the derivative of
a second that's X cosine X plus the
second fact that times the derivative of
the first
that's just sine X the derivative of
cosine X is minus sine X the derivative
of a constant is zero and if we now sum
up the pieces that we have here we wind
up with X cosine X exactly what we were
supposed to get okay now you see again
nothing has happened in theory all we
have now is a technique that allows us
to explicitly solve certain problems
that we couldn't have solved otherwise
even though we could have stated them
before for example let's go back to a
problem that technically speaking we
could have presented before we get to
this unit of our material let's suppose
that the region R is the region bounded
above by y equals cosine X below by the
x-axis between the y-axis and x equals
PI over 2 what we want to do is take
this region R and revolve it about the
y-axis and what we'd like to find is
what volume
is generated when the region R is
revolved about the y-axis now when we
talked about volumes and cylindrical
shells we already had the recipe
recall that to rotate this about the
y-axis just to refresh memories here if
we call this X and we call this Y the
element of volume was what while you
swung out a circumference 2 pi X times
height Y times thickness DX in other
words that the volume when this was
rotated about the y axis was just 2 pi
integral X cosine X DX as X goes from 0
to PI over 2
you see I rigged this particular problem
so we wouldn't have to waste the fact
that we've already found out what the
indefinite integral of X cosine X DX is
in other words we get down to this step
here now by the first fundamental
theorem of integral calculus we know
that whatever this integral is it's also
equal to G of PI over 2 minus G of 0
where G is any function of X whose
derivative with respect to X is the
integrand here which is X cosine X now
you see this part are up to here
we could have got this result without
today's lecture the only thing that we
learned to do today that we couldn't do
before was the idea of how we find a
function whose derivative is X cosine X
in fact what we found was what a
function whose derivative is X cosine X
is just X sine X plus cosine X so by the
first fundamental theorem the answer to
our volume problem is that it's 2pi
times the quantity X sine X plus cosine
X evaluated between 0 and PI over 2
putting an x equals PI over 2 this term
is PI over 2 this term is 0 putting in
the lower limit when x is 0 this term is
0 this term is 1 we subtract the lower
limit that gives us a minus 1 and
therefore the volume that we get is
simply 2 pi times PI over 2 minus 1
again notice then that the only new
thing that we had to do here was devise
a way for finding a function whose
derivative with respect to X was X
cosine X
by the way I think you'll observe over
here that I started in kind of a rigged
fashion namely I started with a specific
u and V it might be interesting to see
how would one tackle this problem if one
had just been given the X cosine X DX
and had to work from there in other
words instead of working backwards now
let's present the problem as it will
come up and a real problem namely all of
a sudden we find that we have to
integrate x cosine X and the idea goes
something like this
you see we say look at if this X weren't
in here this would be pretty easy to
handle so why don't we do this
why don't we call this piece here U and
call this piece here DV then you see D
you would just be DX V would just be
sine X in other words the differential
of sine X is cosine X DX see if u is x d
u is DX if DV is cosine X DX V is equal
to sine X I suppose technically speaking
here I should put in plus a constant but
I'll show later why we can disregard
this constant roughly speaking it just
hinges on the fact that we want only one
solution but we'll talk about that later
for the time being I'll just leave out
the fact that there's a whole family of
functions all I want is one function
whose differential is cosine X DX at any
rate I now apply my recipe namely
integral u DV is equal to u times V
that's X sine X minus integral v which
is sine X times D U which is just dance
in other words integral X cosine X DX is
just X sine X minus sine X DX but I know
how to integrate sine X it's just minus
cosine X therefore replacing integral
sine X DX by minus cosine X plus a
constant the minus cancels here I wind
up with the same result as before only
now hopefully in terms of a smooth flow
not that didn't presuppose the answer
namely this integral is X sine X plus
cosine X plus a constant and by the way
I should mention here that this
technique does require a
in the mouth of engineering in other
words in a given problem where you're
not told what to call you and what to
call V where you have the choice of
picking what's going to be you and
what's going to be DV there is a certain
element of insight that one needs to
guess wisely in this particular problem
it's kind of obvious which way to guess
but let me just to give you the
experience show you what happens when
you guess incorrectly for example given
the same problem why couldn't I have
said gee I think I'll let cosine X bu
and what's left over namely X DX that
will be DV now notice that
mathematically no harm is done this way
namely if u is cosine X D U is minus
sine X DX
if DV is X DX V is 1/2 x squared and now
applying the recipe integral UDV is what
it's UV that's 1/2 x squared times
cosine X minus the integral VDU but VD U
is already minus 1/2 x squared sine X DX
so minus that is plus 1/2 integral x
squared sine X DX and I wind up with the
result that the integral x cosine X DX
is 1/2 x squared cosine X plus 1/2
integral x squared sine X DX and there
is absolutely nothing at all wrong with
this except that the chances are if I
didn't know how to find the function
whose derivative was X cosine X what is
the likelihood that I know a function
whose derivative is x squared sine X DX
in other words here's a case where
replacing U DV by VD you gave me an
equivalent integral to evaluate which
was more cumbersome than the first in
fact somehow or other it would seem that
by multiplying through here by 2 and
solving for x squared sine X DX that it
would seem that somehow or other this
would be a way of simplifying the
integral x squared sine X DX in other
words that if you were started with this
I think you'd accept the fact well this
still isn't as nice as I'd like it but
does seem less complicated than this you
see at least the power of X is only to
the first power here whereas here it's
to the second power
in fact this leads to a technique called
a reduction formula again using
hindsight rather than foresight having
motivated the integral x squared sine X
DX let's see how I could have solved
this particular problem if I didn't know
what the answer was going to be in
advance
you see I said to myself you know this x
squared here is bothering me if an x
squared weren't here this would be
pretty easy to handle well the best way
to knock the x squared down is to let u
equal x squared
in which case D U will be 2x DX in other
words your second power will now be
replaced by a first power it's not
perfect but at least this hope here at
any rate what I'm saying is motivated
into calling you x squared and therefore
letting DV be the rest of this integrand
which is sine x DX we wind up with the
fact that T U is 2x DX and V is minus
cosine X well you see now remembering
that U is x squared DV is sine X DX the
recipe tells us that integral u DV is U
times V that's minus x squared cosine X
minus integral VDU but integral VDU is
integral twice X cosine X DX with a
minus sign the minus sign in the recipe
makes it plus and we therefore wind up
with that integral x squared sine X DX
is equal to minus x squared cosine X
plus twice integral X cosine X DX by the
way just to refresh your memories on
this if we come back and compare this
with what we had over here it's exactly
the same thing the only difference now
is that we arrived at this thing
directly now you see the point is having
reduced this to this I can now use
integration by parts again to simplify
this in other words what I would do next
is let u equal X and DV B cosine X DX
but let's face it I've already done this
problem
time is getting short why do it again
the point is that integral X cosine X
using integration by parts again is
going to come out to be X sine X plus
cosine X plus C because that's what we
got before when we use integration by
parts to do this and any rate what I
would now do is replace integral X
cosine X in here by this okay and if I
do that I have what integral x squared
sine X DX okay is equal to what - x
squared cosine x + twice times this
which is twice this that's what two X
sine X plus two cosine X plus a constant
and by the way again notice if I wanted
to check where this was right the one
thing I can do if somebody gives me this
is what I can differentiate it with
respect to X when I differentiate
respect to X if I get x squared sine X
as my result this is correct otherwise
I've made a mistake but the idea is keep
in mind that these can always be checked
because they're inverse derivatives they
can always be checked by actual
differentiation and again notice the
beauty of this technique if somebody
said construct a function whose
derivative with respect to X as x
squared sine X notice how difficult it
would be to try to piece this thing
together to notice the difference
between being able to check that this is
the right answer and how one would find
this this is the technique or the power
of integration by parts in fact in
making up exam questions this is exactly
how professor sometimes do this that
what you start with is you start with
this then give a person this problem and
tell them to differentiate this and that
whole mess simply comes out to be x
squared sine X and that's why a lot of
times when you have a messy problem to
differentiate and you look at the answer
in the back of the book you become
amazed to see that the thing really
simplified again notice the idea the
integrand here is relatively simple what
we have to differentiate to get that
relatively simple integrand is not quite
so simple
but enough about that let me just go on
with a few more examples see I have
plenty of examples in the exercises to
keep you busy and to give you drill on
this all I'm trying to do now is to
motivate places where one would want to
use integration by parts well let me
show you one place that might be used
one place that it's always worth trying
is when you look at the integrand
haven't the vaguest notion as to how to
integrate it but you are able to
differentiate it you see you've got
nothing to lose the worst that will
happen is that the resulting integral
VDU will be no easier to handle than the
original UDV but at least as a chance
that something will work but let me give
you a for instance i see i've written
this rather badly this is not Stan this
is the integral of inverse tangent X DX
okay
integral inverse tangent X DX what
function has its derivative equal to
inverse tangent X well you see the thing
I do know hopefully is what the
derivative of inverse tangent X is the
derivative of inverse tangent X with
respect to X is 1 over 1 plus x squared
and by the way if you don't know this
there's no hope of even beginning the
integration by parts in other words we
have to assume that we can do something
in a problem like this at any rate
knowing this what do I do next I say
well since I know how to differentiate
the inverse tangent that's a very
natural thing to call you because I can
certainly find D you moreover the nice
thing is that calling DV DX if I can't
if I can integrate anything it's
certainly DX namely what I'm saying is
if u equals inverse tan X and DV is DX
then D u is DX over 1 plus x squared and
V is just equal to X now therefore
integral inverse tan XD X in other words
integral u DV is just what it's still
just u times V that's x times inverse
tan X minus minus VD u that's minus
integral x times DX over 1 plus x
squared now look what happens in this
case obviously with time being short and
having other places to show you my
failures namely in the exercises I pick
one that worked nicely
his Acacia see
the integral inverse tan xdx by using
parts becomes replaced by integral x DX
over 1 plus x squared this is one I can
handle by from before this is one where
the substitution u equals one plus x
squared works very nicely for me or if
you're getting glib with these things
just observe that this integrand is 1/2
natural log 1 plus x squared because how
would you differentiate natural log 1
plus x squared it would just be what 1
over 1 plus x squared times the
derivative of this which is 2x the 2 and
the 1/2 would cancel and we just have
left x over 1 plus x squared in other
words again notice that the answer here
is what this is the function that one
would have to differentiate with respect
to X to wind up with inverse tan X I'll
show you another example in a few
minutes what I did just remember is that
I mentioned Y we can drop the arbitrary
constant let me just take a minute here
and show how this problem should have
really been worked if we wanted to be
precise here which is OK
u equals inverse tan X therefore D U is
DX over 1 plus x squared that part's
fine then we say ok DV is DX
now if DV is DX what must V be well V
could be X but it must be something of
the form X plus some constant which I'll
call c1 could I have chosen V to be X
plus c1
why not in fact what would have happened
if I did that notice that would have
happened in this case is that u times V
now would simply have been X plus c1
times inverse tan X where as integral V
do you instead of being xdx over 1 plus
x squared would have been X plus c1 DX
over 1 plus x squared in other words
leaving the constant in I would get this
and now all I want you to see here and
I've done this just for this particular
example and in the exercises we'll work
it out in general the whole idea is this
this of course can be written as two
terms one of which is X inverse tan X
and the other of which is c1 inverse tan
X
this also can be written as two
integrals namely with the minus sign
kept aside here this is integral X DX
over 1 plus x squared and plus integral
C 1 DX over 1 plus x squared the -
making this - but we know that the
integral DX over 1 plus x squared is
inverse tan inverse tan X in other words
if we now separate these into pieces we
have what X inverse 10x minus integral X
DX over 1 plus x squared and notice that
the C 1 term drops out because we have C
1 inverse tan X occurring twice it's
this term here and it's also it's also
this part of our integral and see what
the minus sign here they just cancel out
and that's why we really don't have to
keep the arbitrary constant in there but
if we wish to we may at any rate let me
summarize with just one more problem to
make sure that we have the technique
down fairly pat let's suppose we were
given integral log X DX what we
certainly do know I hope by this time is
that the derivative of log X with
respect to X is 1 over X since I can
differentiate log X it becomes very
meaningful to try letting u equal log X
if I do this U is log X DV is DX D u
then becomes 1 over X DX and V is X and
now I put in plus C in parentheses here
to indicate that if you wanted to use it
you could at any rate what happens now
integral UDV integral log X DX in this
case is u times V which is X log X minus
integral VDU where you see the x times
the 1 over X is just 1 therefore VD U is
just DX so - that is just minus DX in
other words - the integral VDU
is just minus integral DX and now you
see I have what X log X and this is very
easy to integrate it just happens to be
minus X then I attack on the arbitrary
constant again to check whether this was
the right answer all I have to do is
differentiate X log X - X with respect
X and see if I get log X and I will okay
now how would I use the problem like
this say in a practical situation well
for example suppose I wanted to find the
area of the region R where R was the
region bounded above by the curve y
equals natural log X below by the x-axis
on the left by x equals 1 and on the
right by x equals B where B can be any
number you want right now
as long as it's bigger than 1 in this
diagram notice that the definite
integral says that the area of the
region R is the definite integral from 1
to B log X DX and the first fundamental
theorem of integral calculus says look
if you happen to know a function whose
derivative with respect to X is log X
you can evaluate this thing very quickly
namely it's just G of B minus G of 1
where G prime of X is log X well you see
we do know a function now whose
derivative with respect to X is log X
namely X log X minus X consequently to
solve this problem all I have to do is
evaluate this between the limits of 1
and B which I won't bother doing right
now
okay now here's the idea what we've
really learned here is one more powerful
technique for evaluating integrals how
we arrived at integrals in no way
changes in this particular lecture all
we have now is what a new technique
whereby we evaluate U DV by being able
to evaluate equivalently V D U at any
rate that finishes up what we had in
mind for today and so until next time
goodbye funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate